okay so in this video I want to talk
about some of the details of the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex I
previously mentioned that there are
three enzymatic activities on the
enzymes were called the e 1 e 2 and e 3
and E 1 is specifically the pyruvate
dehydrogenase which also is called a
decarboxylase there's a key coenzyme
there that's TPP the thymine
pyrophosphate and the reaction catalyzed
by that enzyme is the oxidative
decarboxylation of pyruvate e 2 has the
type dihydrolipoyl transacetylase and
the lipo 8 or lipoamide
coenzyme is key there and effectively
what happens there is the transferring
of the acetyl group to coenzyme a and
dihydrolipoyl dehydrogenase is e 3 and F
ID is used there so that's the key there
and what happens there is the
regeneration of the oxidized form of
liability or lipoamide
ok so let's talk a little bit more about
this so I figured I'd draw coenzyme a
just to kind of show you what it looks
like we have coenzyme a we typically
represent as Co ash and the reason why
is the co a portion is not as important
as the this end right here the the SH is
right here from this thigh all group
that comes from this beta
mercaptoethanol it because it's
obviously huge and really this this
portion right here is the most important
portion we can see here that the the
molecule is made up of this portion here
from pantothenic acid which is vitamin
b5 and this portion over here which is
the 3 prime phosphate adenosine
diphosphate which is a nucleotide I
figured I'd mentioned it the function of
coenzyme a here and elsewhere is to
carry acyl groups an acyl group is just
when you have a carbonyl like this and
some R group connected to something so
that is an acyl group so carries acyl
groups with high energies diode
linkages and that's when you have the
the the ESCO a there it's a high-energy
bond that activates acyl groups and
allows the donation of acyl groups and
the one that we mentioned just a moment
ago in the previous video is an acetyl
group specifically which is just a small
acyl group so TPP or thiamine
pyrophosphate is shown here it comes
from thiamine which is vitamin b1 a
deficiency in that enzyme causes very
very we'll talk more about vitamins
later but the function of TVP here and
elsewhere is that it's a cofactor and
decarboxylation reactions
okay so specifically oxidative
decarboxylation x' okay
lipo eight looks like this over here and
its function is as an electron and acyl
group carrier and we'll see how that
kind of works when we look at the
reaction of the complex and these two
sulfur's here and that that linkage are
pretty important so that there's lipo 8
which is the conjugate base of lipoic
acid if i protonated this here that
would be lipoic acid and that is my boy
but in the pyruvate dehydrogenase
complex it's connected to a lysine
residue or lifestyle residue that's
actually part of e2 so if you have if
you get rid of a water here all right if
you get rid of water you make this amide
linkage and now you have lipoamide so
this is what it actually looks like as
part of the enzyme right this actually
bound as a sort of prosthetic group in
you to of the pd h complex okay so some
people got mad at me when i talked about
life away being a cofactor they said no
it's actually lipoamide they're just
getting kind of crazy but this is the
distinction here right this is lipo a
here and this is like oh my gosh
connected to e2f ad fadh2 and 80-plus
NADH they function as electron carriers
reduced electron carriers and I show
that there from vitamin b2 and Levin b3
practically but I don't have them drawn
here they function like I just said as
electron carriers if you want to look at
their their structures just conduct a
quick internet search and you can find
them but they're kind of big and I don't
want take up too much space or time so
let's scroll down to what's going on
here we have the five steps catalyzed by
the actual complex and we're going to
show them with this little drawing here
maybe scroll in between this and little
drawing as the video goes through
you